the right thinks that this is funny  whereas i see a guy who's lost his  connection to reality probably worthy of  a psych eval take a look at this did i  think they think this is funny maybe the  voices are supposed to be funny what  happened was people like hey  what you know  did you see  that and also i was like rusher wants to  go to war  and people like do they really want to  go to war yeah ah russia you know what  um no more mandates uh maybe some  mandates uh  put you you know what really like what  is the critique here is the critique  that there are things in the news like i  i am not i don't know what he's what is  the point here hogan's  they are losing  grip  the right loves this guy i'm going to  show you a video in a second where  they're in hysterics it's almost like is  do you normally watch paint dry to the  point where this is entertaining